sukuna just turned the tables on
everyone again but could this be another
trick by G could this be sua's final W
before his imminent downfall and death
are we about to get another Gojo type
debate where it looks like he just won
only for his death to be revealed in the
next chapter something is off here and
that twist at the end was crazy so let's
get into it I don't going to tell you
guys how this works you guys know how
this works if you enjoy my videos and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment for the YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel attain special grade status by
hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are so close finally this video will of
course contain jjk manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the last chapter we
learned that the shocking death of kendu
with the hands of Utah was all part of
an elaborate master plan that was
concocted long before the battle with
sukuna even began we also learned that
the sorcerers have placed a great deal
of faith on higuma domain and more
specifically in his ability to summon
the Executioner sword a sword that is
believed to be able to kill kill
literally anyone even the king of curses
the rest of the chapter was then spent
on discussing the various charges that
judg man could potentially bring against
sukuna and this left much of the fandom
thinking that we were about to see a
courtroom Showdown with sukuna there
were all these memes about like Saul
Goodman acting as his defense attorney
and so on but as the new chapter reveals
things are going to move a lot more
quickly and a lot more dramatically than
just some legal court case drama the new
chapter starts off with the fight
between hakari and Ura hakari is trying
to keep Ura from linking up with sukuna
and helping him further since let's be
real the king of curses is overpowered
enough already without the help of his
little haon era sidekick Ur is using
massive amounts of ice cursed energy to
attack hakari but hakari is able to
counter with his incredible martial arts
abilities and his own powerful cursed
energy cursed energy that is notoriously
rough and it makes hakari one of the
sorcerers with the most potential Ur
confirms that thanks to his innate
technique hakari has absolutely
incredible healing speed and it's to the
point that it even surpasses sukuna and
Gojo it's safe to assume that hakari
managed to hit the jackpot last time he
activated his domain so now he's
practically unkillable the two
combatants then get into a bit of T no
jutu about human nature and whether
Sorcerers should still regard themselves
as human especially after their powers
continue to grow but the talking doesn't
last long and Ur and hakari quickly go
back to their epic showdown meanwhile
the trial against sukuna for the Shibuya
Massacre is in full Wing higuma explains
to judg man that even though Yuji is the
accused because the crimes were
committed with his body he is actually
innocent because at that time his body
was being controlled by his codefendant
Ryan sukuna huruma begins to make his
case stating that unless sukuna can
demonstrate that he was having some sort
of mental issues at the time of the
massacre he must be found guilty and
responsible for committing the
atrocities that took place in chiuya but
sukuna doesn't have much interest in
hearing higuma big prosecutor speech he
is fully aware of the rules of this
domain since he went through it all
already when he was back inside yuji's
body and the only thing that sukuna
cares about is the infamous executioner
sword sukuna essentially says that he
doesn't care about this legal process
practically insulting judg man and
admitting his guilt along the way and so
judg man quickly rules that sukuna is
guilty and the punishment will be
confiscation and the death penalty now
what does this mean it means that sukuna
will lose the ability to use his innate
technique and on top of that higuma will
be granted the power to use the
Executioner sword in order to end sukuna
once and for all and yet once his severe
sentences read aloud sukuna simply
smirks he doesn't seem worried at all on
the contrary he's acting like everything
is going according to plan huruma is
then granted the use of the Executioner
sword and he begins to assess the
situation as he plans to bring about Suk
kuna's downfall higuma believes that
suk's ability to use 10 Shadows might
have been confiscated by judge man but
it's even more likely that his primary
innate ability Shrine is the one that
has been confiscated sukuna losing the
ability to use his primary innate
technique along with higuma possessing a
special sword that delivers guaranteed
kills means that the sorcerers finally
have a realistic chance of taking sukuna
down but don't forget this is Jutsu
Kaizen so just as things are finally
looking a bit hopeful for the sorcerers
and just as it seems that sukuna may be
about to be at a serious disadvantage it
turns out that sukuna gets the last
laugh yet again as higuma prepares to
attack sukuna with the sword he suddenly
starts getting slashed all over his body
and then we see kusakabe running into
the fight and trying to absorb some of
the slashes to protect higuma with his
own body we also see brief glimpses of
choso and Eno implying that they may be
joining the fight soon but as of this
chapter they did not show up on the
battlefield in that moment huruma
realizes that if a Target is in
possession of a cursed weapon then judge
man's confiscation will be applied to
that weapon instead of the target's
curse technique this means that the only
thing that was confiscated from sukuna
was the power of that cursed tool that
Ur had given him back in chapter
237 and now that their plan to
neutralize sukuna in N technique has
failed both higuma and kusakabe are
facing certain death at the hands of
suk's Relentless slashing attacks the
only way to save them now is for someone
else to step up and potentially make use
of the Executioner sword in hiur place
if that is even possible let's be real
higu Malone can't go toe-to-toe with
sukuna but if someone more powerful were
to wield that superhuman weapon then we
would be getting somewhere in the
previous chapter we were told that after
he takes out Kaku UTA will have to hurry
back to the side of the battle against
sukuna so it's likely that UTA is about
to return and save the others by taking
on sukuna himself possibly by using The
Executioner's sword if there is some way
for higuma to transfer the use of the
sword to UT and if UTA is not going to
step in just yet then our boy Yuji will
definitely have to dig deep and reveal
the true nature of his power right now
otherwise many of the sorcerers will die
in the very next chapter because the
plan to deprive sukuna of his primary
inate technique has clearly failed so
what's next are higuma kusakabe and a
bunch of other side characters about to
be one-shotted and Kia by sukuna listen
it's definitely possible that a couple
of sorcerers are going to be dropped for
Good by sukuna jjk doesn't mess around
and suguna has already killed off a
whole bunch of significant characters in
the story so it could happen however I
have a feeling that at the very least
higuma Will Survive because his
executioner sword is definitely going to
play some role in this fight and the two
other characters who are going to play a
major role are Utah and Yuji let's be
real unless zombie Gojo returns from the
dead no single sourcerer will be able to
do a thing against sukura their only
chance is to engage in some absolutely
meticulous teamwork and to make full use
of their unique curse techniques these
curse techniques have to work together
with each other in order to catch sukuna
off guard now with all the focus that
was given to the fight between Gojo and
sukuna the two strongest Sorcerers in
history I feel like many people forgot
just how overpowered UTA otu actually is
and like I said unless Gojo gets wished
back with the Dragon Balls UTA will
surely play a key role in the fight
against sukuna we know that he is a
descendant of the legendary sorcerer
michan sugar the same ancient sorcerer
who is credited with founding the Gojo
Clan because he is part of this
prestigious bloodline UTA has an
immeasurable amount of cursed energy
even more than Gojo he also has access
to Raa the queen of curses Raa has
nearly endless cursed energy that can be
shaped into any technique allowing Utah
to copy the cursed techniques of others
while he is connected to Rea UTA also
has absolutely insane skills when it
comes to reverse cursed energy he can
use it to heal himself and he can also
use it to heal other people in fact he
was literally able to kill Yuji and then
bring him back from the dead that's how
overpowered his revers cursed energy is
the only other person who was able to do
this was of course sukuna so this tells
you something about uta's true power and
potential the man can even heal poison
in others he is just that op again I'm
not saying that UTA alone can take
sukuna but I do think that UT is rushing
back to the main Battlefield right now
because he is about to play a major role
in this fight what's more the fact that
we know that Utah is a skilled swordsman
suggests to me that he may be the one to
wield the Executioner sword against
sukuna but even with all that UT is
going to need a lot of help to take
sukuna down some of that help may come
from Side characters like huruma and
kusakabe but I think that alongside Utah
the most important role in the battle
against sukuna will be played by none
other than Yuji you guys follow the
manga you watch my videos so you all
know the theory that yuji's body is
currently learning to use Suk innate
technique as we speak I won't rehash at
all here but I think that yuji's
eventual ability to use sukuna curse
technique combined with his power to
manipulate Souls will allow Yuji UTA and
the others to pose a real threat to
sukuna in this fight the next generation
of jiutu sorcerers is about to take
center stage and I expect big things
from utai and Yuji and to a lesser
extent from hakari as well in the end
everyone will have to work together and
make the best of all of their different
curse techniques in order to stand a
chance in this fight and even then the
deck is still stacked against them even
if all of these guys came together and
executed the perfect strategy against
sukuna with the perfect teamwork and
even if they somehow incapacitated or
maybe even killed sukuna even then it
might not be over remember what Kaku
said a few chapters ago even if he dies
there is already someone else out there
who will carry on his will it's highly
unlikely that Kaku was talking about
sukuna here sukuna only cares about
himself so I don't see him trying to
carry on kaku's will it's it's likely
that Kaku is talking about someone else
and it's likely that this other person
is directly connected to kaku's decision
to kidnap master tangan and it's likely
that all of this is about to go down in
the next few chapters so I can't wait to
see what happens next what do you guys
think can full power Utah with the
Executioner sword and new power Yuji
actually threatens sukuna what is kaku's
master plan and who is carrying on his
will are you still coping about Gojo's
death or have you accepted it I still
think he's coming back you guys I know
it sounds crazy but I am still coping by
the way if you're wondering what kind of
Soul manipulation power I was talking
about earlier when I mentioned Yugi's
new secret power check out this video
where I explain it all in full link on
screen and in the description if you
enjoyed this jjk video and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like right now and if you want to help
this channel attain special great status
by hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and subscribe right now we
are so close